um but one of the things which i feel
like it's so important to talk about it
might be one of the last things
which we discuss is the fact that we've
kind of alluded to this in our
conversation um right from the start you
know i mentioned
you've been speaking to different
ministries of health around the world
and many people might have heard that
and thought a mathematician
why would a mathematician not you know a
medical doctor
be sort of you know interfacing with
this world and that's of course because
we are in the midst of a global pandemic
something which
you know the world has seen before but
not in this age of you know
people flying globally around the world
of of the internet and of the technology
that we've got
and i don't know about this and your
experience but i've certainly found
as the coronavirus has spread in terms
of
what you know everyday people are
absorbing from the world around them
there hasn't been a time
where we've seen as much mathematics
incorporated into
just a news report you know we've been
seeing uh graphs with logarithmic scales
we've been talking about
percentage infection rates uh false
positives and false negatives
all that kind of thing pool testing and
how that works in fact the wonderful
mathematics underneath it
but one thing that's been hugely
important has been
contact tracing now i guess i'm
interested
in you know contact tracing has been
something that we've now sort of
added into our lingo for how we fight
this disease but
i'm interested first before we talk
about you know what you and your team
have been working on to help
solve that problem why is it so
important now why is contact tracing
like when we fight other diseases
we don't always think about it in these
terms can you help us understand
why this is such a powerful tool and
what mathematics has to do with it
yeah so i'll give you an answer that a
mathematician would give because what we
try to do is we as mathematicians we
always try to figure out
what is different you know like in
mathematics you have a few assumptions
and from those assumptions you draw a
conclusion
how come suddenly this disease is
different from the others i would
isolate that one of the key
aspects is that it transmits before you
know you have
you have the disease the fact that you
start to become
highly contagious two days 48 hours
before your symptoms start
makes this a very very difficult disease
to control
because it makes it so you can't use our
natural human
instincts normally the way we do
something is oh i feel like i have a
fever or i have a i have a runny nose
i won't go into work today that works
great
as long as the disease only starts
spreading then
but if the disease starts spreading
before then then suddenly
the problem is that you have people
running around getting other people sick
finally realizing that they're sick
maybe at that point doing something
but it's too late some other people got
sick they're running around they get
more people sick
then they find out they're sick then
they go back in but it's too late and
the exponential growth takes off
so if i were to boil it down i'd say the
very unusual thing is the highly high
amount of contagion
before you know that you have it now
that contact tracing component the way
the rest of the world has been trying to
attack this
is they've been trying to chase as fast
as they can
because if you go and find out that
there's somebody who had it it's
actually very natural and logical that
you go and try to see who were these
people around
can we intercept them and quickly rein
them in
because maybe that would control the
virus not maybe it does work there are
countries which have used this to great
success
and so i think that's why contact
tracing became a thing
so that makes a lot of sense because it
is a transformation of the problem isn't
it which i love it's just a
you know it's a keystone mathematical
problem-solving strategy
um but you're right that even though you
know we have measures that do work of
course we're saying
if you are sick definitely do stay home
but because of this
nature of the problem where you know
before that happens actually we've
already got this spread and as you're
alluding to before with networks
we live especially around the world now
in our cities in such incredible density
and so in some ways even though usually
being in a city you know brings
significant advantages you know you have
access to all of these things very
conveniently
but right now it's kind of working in
the opposite direction the closer you
are you are to other people the more
struggles there are and so that's why
you know you and your team have
devised this kind of different contact
tracing app that takes a very different
approach and it's called
novid which i love obviously we've
already seen from xb you know you have a
penchant for fantastic
and memorable names novid not covert
can you tell us how does this app work
why is it different
so that's where the network theory comes
in right so i actually
do think about networks all the time and
when kovit broke out it's very
interesting actually the last person
that i had a serious mathematical
conversation with about education was in
fact you
i saw you in australia and that was
right before a lot of these restrictions
shut down and
as i was getting back into the u.s
that's when behind me basically doors
were shutting
of you know all the places i'd been
before they were shutting down
and at that point i started to think is
there anything i can do to try to help
with this problem
and i realized that due to the fact that
this disease is spreading before you
know you have it
then maybe i can try to do something
with network theory but after thinking
about it for months and months and
working on
various versions of apps we came up with
something that is completely different
from this traditional catching up method
in fact we actually would even consider
it to be a paradigm shift
and i'll say this in the in the
framework of network theory normally
what happens is when there's somebody
who's infected the normal contact
tracing apps and the normal contact
tracing method
will go find everybody who was directly
exposed those are the neighbors of that
node
and they would ask all those people to
please quarantine and please isolate
unfortunately that actually hasn't
worked so well we came up with something
else we said what if for every person
who is positive who's infected what if
you told everyone else
how many relationships away that person
was
don't tell them who it is but this is
the transformation right we're not going
to just report true or false were you
exposed
we're going to tell everyone you were
seven relationships away you were two
relationships away
well what's the use of this the value is
first of all what's a relationship a
relationship if you use an app like
we actually made an app for this um a
relationship is measured by two people
actually being in about the same place
for at least 15 minutes
so that's how we make this network right
we build this huge network that's
in fact a worldwide network and then
what happens is if you want to know
what's your relationship distance you
just count how many steps
it's almost like if i have uh if i if i
if
i so if i'm here and i know somebody not
know somebody if i'm here
and i spend time with somebody who
spends time with somebody who spends
time with somebody who got
coveted that would be a distance of
three but the reason why this is useful
is that you can then animate this like
like a weather radar chart you can
actually animate a bar
chart which shows how the disease is
approaching
to you and you can use that
to directly avoid getting sick because
with this tool
if you can see the disease coming
towards you
it actually it gives you a new way for
all of humanity to fight
contagious diseases actually that's the
thing that is most amazing to me at this
point
that in this year 2020 it could be that
we have come up with
a totally new tool for humanity to fight
any disease that spreads through
person-to-person contact
the tool is radar and the right way to
measure your radar
is to use the network distance because
it's not useful to say
there is a coveted case over there 20
meters in front of me
the reason that's not useful is usually
that person doesn't even know they have
coveted
so how would that even work there's no
way to do that if they knew they had
coveted they wouldn't be standing there
the problem with covet and all these
other diseases is that you don't know
you have it
so a radar should not be based on meters
instead the right way to do the radar is
how does kobe get to you
or it gets to you from someone you spend
time with how does it get to them
from someone they spend time with this
is where the network theory comes in so
that's where since i was a network
theorist
i said it's very simple for every case
just report the network
theoretic distance between that case and
you
but suddenly if you've got this app
you are empowered to protect yourself
because we've asked a lot of people what
would you do if you saw the disease
closing in
people said things like oh i would make
sure to wear a very good mask maybe even
an n95 mask
that protects me more than the typical
cloth masks or maybe
if i'm in public with other people at my
workplace i might keep
more distance than usual not just the
two meters or
if i have the opportunity to i might
choose to work remotely
but i'm just explaining that there are
all these different actions that you can
take
to do something to protect yourself and
if you just
knew that something was on its way in
you could defend yourself against the
invisible disease
i think one of the things i so love
about this approach is that
it takes number one a tool that we
wouldn't necessarily think about
as one that's like oh that's that's
something has a direct
connection to to medicine or health or
indeed anything necessarily
very practical but actually because of
the nature of the problem here
it's not just a medical problem as you
pointed out it's an information
problem and i think this sort of gets to
the fact that so many of us
our response to this pandemic has been
significantly colored by do we know
someone
do we personally have knowledge of
someone who perhaps has gotten sick
or had you know a relative who has and
so in fact we are still using
that uh that strategy as it were but in
a very very weak form because we have to
be reliant on
well did that person definitely um and
did they do they get very sick and in
fact you know we're reliant on the fact
that
all of that is non-anonymous we have to
know these people personally
before any of that knowledge is
transmitted to us but covert doesn't
care if you know people personally or
not it will spread regardless
and so that's actually a key part of the
app and how it works right that there's
this anonymous
aspect to it could you talk us through a
bit of that mechanic and how that
applies to the app yes
so when people were talking about
contact tracing back in say march
that was a very non-anonymous form of
somebody calling you to say who were you
around where did you eat dinner last
night and they were doing it with names
and my observation was as a network
theorist with kobe doesn't care who you
are
kovy just cares that these two people
were near each other and so all you
really need is a way to figure out
with pseudonyms without knowing who a
person really is if you install the app
the app makes up a random pseudonym for
you it's actually a
128-bit number which is about a 40-digit
number approximately but like some very
long number that represents your
identity
without actually representing your
identity no mobile number right so the
way that we built this is
if you install this app it doesn't ask
you for a mobile number it doesn't ask
you for your
residence id number it doesn't ask you
for anything it just makes it id for you
and then as you're wandering around in
public if you happen to have the app and
somebody else has the app then the two
discover that
all right these two random numbers were
near each other
but since we intentionally don't want to
know anyone's identity
all we do is we build up this big
anonymous network
and the observation was you know what if
these anonymous
participants could just find out that
there is a wave of incoming covered
towards them
where you tell it to them in ways that
also protect the anonymity like
it's at distance four how many people
are distance four
maybe there are twenty or maybe they're
thirty i can't tell who it is but it
doesn't matter is that distance four
and once you get this information the
natural outcome
would be it's very interesting natural
outcome would be that
around everywhere that the disease was
people would start to
freak out in a good way freak out in a
good way of trying to
defend themselves but this is another
thing about the math here
the act of defending yourself from
getting sick is symmetric
it also prevents you from getting anyone
else sick in case you were an
asymptomatic or pre-symptomatic spreader
so again this is the math part of
geeking out over here is that somehow
if you actually had an app like this
here's what you'd actually see
you wouldn't see a national lockdown you
would just see that wherever the disease
went
around that disease out to maybe three
social circles
people are making themselves scarce and
reducing the spread of the disease
in fact stamping it out in fact maybe
maybe in your book if you
if you have any discussion discussions
of convergence this is basically a
dynamic process
which causes the number of cases to
converge to zero
because wherever it is there's a natural
pressure to reduce
the amount of action amount of
interaction
and that stamps out the cases the reason
this is so important
is because the way that we traditionally
as human kind are trying to fight
diseases
is the opposite we aren't converging to
zero we're converging
to cases because whenever there are
fewer cases we release
and then people start to move around
more until there are too many cases and
then we lock down
the math of this is that you're
guaranteeing to converge towards always
having cases
whereas the difference in what we're
doing is that you might not need to lock
down everybody
but there might be around that one case
10 people who are freaking out
and by freaking out there's no more
spread and then there's no more one case
so this is this is actually what i'm
really excited about these days about
how
you know you could use this network
theory insight on math
to go and make a totally new
intervention a totally new type of tool
which can be used alongside every tool
we use to fight disease
but could be as powerful as a radar in
stopping the spread of disease
that is incredible because like you said
um you know as you were mentioning
before
we have this rhythm of you know cases
rise so then we act
and then you know if the action works
then cases drop
but then we necessarily relax because
you know the economy is being affected
and so on but there is going to be this
rhythm established this equilibrium
which by necessity has some cases around
because it is a
reactive solution you know we respond
once we see the cases so they're already
there
whereas this is kind of it almost allows
for a forecasting situation as you
mentioned
as you're watching the numbers the um
relationships you know perhaps it starts
at seven
then it goes six five and four and then
you realize oh i can actually respond to
something
i see coming before it actually arrives
and that's what changes the dynamics so
wonderfully right
yeah actually this is where we i think
about all of these things of what is
different here right
and there's another thing that's very
different once you can see it coming
with a longer range distance
for the first time the app gives you a
direct way to avoid getting sick
whereas if you compare with the other
apps that say google and apple have been
building systems for those apps are all
designed in ways where it doesn't tell
you anything
until after you've already been exposed
to somebody else who's positive
and then the app tells you please
quarantine
now this is very different because at
that point there's no more time
to do anything to protect yourself from
other people
the ask is please protect everyone else
from you and this is where game theory
comes in actually this is this is
another
very interesting angle there's a notion
of what's called a nash equilibrium
and nash equilibrium is what happens uh
it's
it's a state of affairs where nobody has
any incentive to deviate
that's one way you could call a nash
equilibrium all right and you can even
think of this in terms of human behavior
it's like could we say let's all agree
on the following strategy
if it's in equilibrium then that would
mean that nobody has incentive to cheat
but you see in that in that app that
i've just described the way that apple
and google are making their system
imagine everyone was using it you would
have plenty of incentive to uninstall
because if you uninstall everyone else
is still protecting you from
them and you don't have to quarantine
i'm actually saying this is
bad behavior that's selfish don't do
that but the unfortunate thing is that
the selfish equilibrium for that system
is actually nobody installs it whereas
what we've done is we said
let's not try to drive any quarantines
with this app let's just instead of
calling it quarantine of protecting
everyone from you
give you enough foresight that while
you're busy buying enough toilet paper
for the next 10
years because everyone will do anything
to protect themselves a little bit more
this is true
while you do that you effectively cause
all of the impact that was wanted
except that you actually got to protect
yourself and then the nash equilibrium
here becomes
the equilibrium becomes that everyone
installs it it's actually once you make
it so that it satisfies the following
mathematical property called
installing app decreases your chance of
getting covet
that is actually the property that ours
has if you install the app you decrease
your chance of getting covet
surprisingly that is not what all of the
other apps had they had the property
that if you install it you decrease
other people's chances of getting
covered while you increase your chance
of getting quarantined
so these are the sorts of things that we
think yeah you were referencing before
some massive ideas there you know game
theory for example
is an area of mathematics that uh many
people sort of your average person on
the street has never encountered during
their you know their school experience
but what you mentioned of the fact that
we are all in a sense
sort of we have this natural inclination
towards selfish behavior towards
self-protective
behavior at potentially the expense of
other people this is something we
experience
all the time i mean i think about you
know in another lifetime when we were
you know in airports and perhaps we'd
just gotten off the plane
and uh you know there come our suitcases
off the carousel and we're all there
standing around
waiting and as soon as the suitcases
begin you know what would make sense
what would be
helpful to everyone is if we all stood
back so that we could all see clearly
and then
once you're you know you you see it
coming along you say oh well now i will
move forward
and collect my suitcase but in fact that
is not the equilibrium that actually
occurs
everyone gets in as close as possible
because it gives
you an incentive to be able to get to
yours faster
it creates a problem for all the people
behind you but then you know what will
they do
they'll then move forward and then
suddenly we're on the crowd and everyone
pays and i guess we're in a very similar
situation here
where the you know technique that we use
for
contact tracing if it is something that
is clearly going to give me
a benefit it obviously is going to have
a much bigger chance of success and
that's just
human psychology as well isn't it yes
and that's why i i guess i had the idea
that this should be possible because
there's so much
good created by having done the right
thing because then there's less disease
there's an economy that runs there's no
shutdowns this is
exactly what we want so what i as a
mathematician you try to say
if there's this much good could we find
a different way to apportion the good
do you know what i mean and so that's
why when you use the network theory to
give that forewarning
that suddenly apportions enough of the
good to encourage a person to use the
system
that they then use the system and since
there was so much good to go around the
pi is big
so you can actually make it so that
every participant got what they wanted
and everyone got to a better place
whereas the problem was what people were
trying to do before with apps
the good was a portion differently where
it was good for the government and good
for everyone if everyone
collaborated but unfortunately on the
point of view of the individual
it didn't deliver what they may
themselves have chosen to do
so that's what i'm actually right now
really trying to push because
it's it's actually quite rare that an
idea like this does arise i mean
one would normally expect that ideas
like this you've already seen them all
it's the year 2020 right
but i often think like how could
something like this be new well
it might be because this requires lots
of smartphones and this is the first
pandemic we've ever had
where there are lots of bluetooth
enabled smartphones where you could
basically turn
every person into a person who can
defend themselves against the disease
that's it's it's this generational leap
we're not just we have technology but
actually it is
ubiquitous and that's what enables this
uh this particular strategy
to work uh i think this is so brilliant
and i think it is something which
i hope governments around the world are
going to pay attention to
and they're going to realize wow this is
actually a very clever ingenious
and effective way to actually find this
disease
po you've been so generous with your
time thank you so much
for spending today with us good luck as
you speak with all of these different
people
around the world and try and help them
to see um all these different strategies
for attacking this disease and hopefully
overcoming it as well
thanks poe well thank you eddie it's a
real pleasure talking to you again i
can't wait until i can see you in person
again back when the world's back to
normal